the economic downturn has been difficult
recently forcing the closures of both
Camden and Yonkers to be followed soon
by what other branch
for five hundred thousand dollars is it
a Scranton
B Buffalo
C Utica
or D toothbrush I will say B Buffalo
final answer that is correct
David Wallace told me David is this true
okay everyone we're at picnic today
we're losing our jobs or not David they
didn't know I guess not I'm sorry this
certainly wasn't the time or the place
to announce this sort of thing but there
have been talks
about closing the Buffalo branch
and
we're we're closing the Buffalo Branch
gotta be kidding me
kidding me with a perspiration
in the cup how could you possibly think
that the right way to announce a branch
closing was in a comedy sketch at the
company picnic well
I didn't know they didn't know what
about the fact that they're here today
what about that that didn't throw up any
alarms no Michael needed a little bit
for his comedy sketch and he thought oh
this would be really funny thank you
damn it Michael I told you that
confidence now I have to go over and
deal with these employees and their
families
a little boy just walked up to me and
said is my daddy gonna have a job by
Christmas well he's just thinking about
his own gifts
yeah my salaries man what do they expect
you know they take us out every weekend
you know what I mean we're not
millionaires I feel you no you don't you
don't feel us how can you you know what
not literally you say we're the same but
we get compensated very differently yes
we work the same hours as you and you
just said we work a lot harder I you do
so but we get paid a lot less
like next to no benefits I know God what
is that exactly blows it blows man no
this would not happen if we had a union
yeah absolutely right Nancy that's what
I've been saying man we need to do this
finally you know what is that necessary
because you already sort of have a union
of guys it's more than necessary Mike we
need this Roy yeah you still have that
card from the doc workers union and my
Truckers
[Applause]
the chicks and you gotta blame them
are you with us Mike yeah
welcome to the warehouse
huh Michael Michael
another issue is inequality of pay
between men and women I'm sure that all
of you have dealt with that before this
is important please take a breather Jan
uh yeah
wanna
um I wanted to say that the guys
downstairs are thinking about forming a
union and they have some good point a
union hysterical I'm not part of my job
is knowing how to talk to women let's be
rational here
what are the pros the cons are that
everyone will lose their job Michael
everyone office warehouse
what do you think the pro
Pro are here don't talk to me that way
please just
they're going to want to hear this from
you oh you got yourself into this
Michael so you get your bonding down
there I mean I just don't want to have
to tell them something they're not going
to want to hear okay
come on Jan after all we've been through
um
Michael between us don't say another
word get yourself down stairs
all right take care of the situation
yeah yeah yes
I I have excuse me excuse me I'm told
that there's been some interest in
forming a union and that Michael
supported it obviously he's not a friend
of yours because he didn't tell you the
facts so let me
if there is even a whiff of unionizing
in this Branch I can guarantee you the
branch will be shut down like that the
unionized in Pittsfield and we all know
what happened in Pittsfield
it will cost each of you a fortune and
legal fees and union dues and that'll be
nothing compared to the cost of losing
your job so I would think long and hard
before sacrificing your savings and your
futures just to send a message
if you have any further questions you
can direct them to
to Michael
[Music]
hey Creed huh
can I talk to you for a second
you are great and very ambitious
I feel like you want more than this
little office has to offer and I
understand that you'd want to just
spread your wings
fly The Coop what are you telling me
we're gonna have to you you want
something better no I don't I want to
stay right here
yo you want to leave no I won't stay
here why are you making this so hard
um I think there's a misunderstanding I
think you're right can I go no of course
you can't go we haven't even started
this horrible process of
okay Creed I need to let somebody go
today
they told me I need to let somebody go
and as much as I think you're a great
guy and I like you you're you're goodbye
let's fight it let's call Jan and fight
this thing together like the old days
what old days what are you talking about
did you start the paperwork yet it's
right here on the desk yeah you don't
have to do this Michael I can't I can't
undo it Creed's an idiot you know that
well no no no no no no no no no you had
it right the first time wait maybe I did
exactly you gotta go with your gut man
ah
no I can't no I can't go back I would
look like an idiot that's why I'm being
fired no so you might not look like an
idiot no it was all the stuff that I
said it was the business downturn and
cutbacks and and and this is
unbelievable
I just hope that you and I can remain
friends
Deb wait
please look look
in addition to Severance
and everything I want to
give you
this gift certificate to Chili's
for me
okay no hard feelings
it's not sweetie it's Michael Scott
Stephanie could you hop off please
David you are on speakerphone with the
entire branch and the warehouse
they do not believe me when you told me
that everyone was canned
well I think we're past that now I am
not supposed
ly but guys I was really only talking
about Alan myself and a few other execs
you don't know oh my God David that's
horrible
how about us it's Meredith by the way
your wife is a very lucky woman
we're not fired
[Applause]